Loree Laughlin's holidays aren't looking
so cheery as her trial for her alleged
involvement in the college admissions
scandal looms a source tells ET that
while Lori and her family are looking
forward to Christmas the outcome of the
whole ordeal is kind of a dark cloud
hanging over them quote Laurie's world
as she knew it has been shaken beyond
anything she could have imagined Laurie
is doing her best to put on a brave face
she wants nothing more than to have a
wonderful holiday with her family at
home Laurie and her husband fashion
mogul Massimo Jian Uli are accused of
paying half a million dollars in bribes
to get their two daughters Olivia and
Isabella admitted into USC the couple
has pleaded not guilty to the charges
their next court date is set for January
17 but they're not required to attend
our source says Laurie is trying to keep
herself busy to deal with the pressure
of the case including hitting the gym to
relieve stress hi guys welcome back to
my youtube channel meanwhile her
daughter Olivia Jade has returned to
work she's back to posting regularly on
her YouTube channels the 20 year old
beauty vlogger just posted her second
video since the scandal broke she took a
nine-month hiatus from YouTube when the
charges were initially filed against her
parents I'm not allowed to speak on
anything going on right now a part of me
is like should I come back to YouTube
right now because I it's been so long
and I actually really really miss it
like I genuinely miss filming and there
will be more content to come Olivia
teased her followers with this update in
her new tutorial I have a blog I'm still
working on it filming it's just not done
so I wanted to get this video or really
any video up sooner after my initial
video but I'm not talking with it and
I'm still just like easing back into it
so thanks for being patient because
they're awesome
olivia has yet to address what's going
on with her family though I debated for
like seven or eight months like well if
I can't talk
is there a point in coming back and not
being able to say anything I want to
come back because I want to come back
there's no point in me just talking for
10 minutes of the camera about how I
wish I could say something when I really
can't so I'm gonna leave it at that
thank you so much for your patience or
if you've stuck around for nine months
just waiting I really appreciate it
according to our source along with
YouTube olivia is also focusing on her
social circle
she and sister Bella are expected to
spend New Year's Eve with their friends
[Music]